in this lesson we're going to discuss
the coenzyme thiamine pyrophosphate
shown here TPP is involved in the
pyruvate dehydrogenase complex and we're
going to review that mechanism in this
lesson here's the overall reaction that
we're looking at the conversion of
pyruvate to acetyl coenzyme a a thio
ester so we have this sulfur connected
to the carbonyl there and co a I just
want to point out is a very large
structure we often abbreviate it with
these three little letters and you think
it's kind of small but it's actually a
very very large coenzyme itself let's
warm up by discussing the structure of
TPP a little bit this whole portion over
here these two heterocyclic rings are
derived from vitamin b1 or thiamine
thiamine differs because it doesn't have
the phosphate groups here instead it
just has a simple o h thiamine is a
compound that humans cannot
biosynthesize so we need to get it from
our diet
fortunately plant some microorganisms
make this higher organisms consume them
and it moves up the food chain and many
foods are rich in vitamin b1
pyrophosphate refers to the two
phosphate groups linked together and
these come from ATP we have two
heterocycles in this molecule the one
containing two nitrogen atoms is a
pyramidal
now the really important heterocycle in
this molecule is the charged thiazole
ring an inductive effect from the
positively charged nitrogen atom makes
the adjacent proton quite acidic with a
pKa of 18 so in biochemical mechanisms
we'll see that this gets deprotonated
and that's how this can do some pretty
amazing chemistry alright we want to get
into this mechanism but the pyruvate
dehydrogenase complex has quite a few
other coenzymes associated with it so i
just need to introduce those first
before we get started on our MEC one of
the co enzymes that we'll see in this
mechanism is derived from lipoic acid
and there's two things I need to tell
you about it so that we can understand
the chemistry this is going to become
covalently bound
the enzyme via this carboxylic acid but
it is going to attach to a lysine in an
amide linkage and so this carboxylic
acid is going to react and be replaced
by the Amman so you'll often see this
coenzyme called
lippo amat because that's the form that
it's in when it's attached to the enzyme
also this sulfur sulfur bond is pretty
easy to break and so we if we open this
up we'll have two SH s so nucleophiles
can attack at sulfur kicking out sulfur
as a good leaving group and break this
bond here and this results in reduction
of lipoic acid and that'll happen in
this mechanism the other coenzyme we
need is coenzyme a and we looked up that
structure earlier alright to kick this
process off TVP is going to react with
pyruvate
since this sisal is going to be the most
important piece to do the chemistry in
this mechanism I'm gonna abbreviate this
in this way where R is our chain with
the pyrophosphate and R prime is our
perimeter ring up here I've shown this
in the deprotonated form this compound
with a positive and negative charge on
adjacent atoms is called an illidan so
this is the TPP illud generated by
deprotonation of this acidic hydrogen
atom here so at this point with our
negative charge on this this is going to
be the nucleophile in our reaction and
you might be thinking there are two
carbonyls that this can attack well
carboxylic acids are ionized at
biological pH and so we have this
carboxylate so this already has a lot of
negative charge and it's really hard to
attack here but this ketone has a nice
dipole and there's no buildup of
negative charge interfering with this
process and so we're going to get attack
at the carbonyl carbon of the ketone so
when we attack here we need to push
electrons up but in biochemical
mechanisms we can do a little shorthand
and have an acidic enzyme residue help
us along by protonating this when we
push the electrons up
here's the product of our step notice we
still have our positive charge on
nitrogen but we use the negative charge
to attack here and grabbed a proton so
this is our new Oh H that we form from
this carbonyl now the next step is going
to be a decarboxylation of this group
right here and this is going to occur as
you'll see in a minute because we can
neutralize the ring nitrogen right now
we have an aromatic compound so that's
quite stable even though it has this
positive charge on it and when we push
electrons through the system we're going
to disrupt aromaticity here but we're
going to neutralize the positive charge
which is also favorable so let's look at
the arrow pushing for the
decarboxylation to see how this works
these electrons are going to come in
here this carbon that is right there is
going to now have four bonds so this
bond breaks completely will show that
making a new double bond right here and
we have to continue to push electrons
and we can push them onto nitrogen now
the electrons from nitrogen are going to
push back in making this ring aromatic
again we'll have to push these electrons
out and attack something at this point
we're going to bring in our lipoic acid
or Lippo a m''d coenzyme and we're going
to form a bond with the sulfur atom and
cleave the sulfur sulfur bond and when
we open up this ring we're going to need
a hydrogen and that will come from an
acidic residue on the protein so our
arrow pushing will restore the
aromaticity will use this lone pair to
push in this bond is going to attack at
sulfur that makes the sulfur sulfur bond
break we'll grab our proton from the
enzyme and show a lone pair going on to
this generic amino acid residue here
because enzymes catalyze many reactions
very quickly we need to get the coenzyme
back to the way it was so it can attack
another molecule of pyruvate so what
we're going to do is we need to put a
negative charge back on here we can
deprotonate this hydrogen reform a
carbonyl compound and break this bond to
do so let's look at how that happens we
will need a basic enzyme residue to do
that
this is going to attack this proton
these electrons push down and when we're
choosing which bond to break we'll put
the electrons here and reform our illud
and we form this thio ester here on the
lip om and which i've just abbreviated
with an R here instead of writing out
the name of it now this looks a lot like
acetyl coenzyme a we have our thio ester
but we need to just switch out our R
thio ester for the ESCO a ester so we
can bring in our next coenzyme and do a
transesterification reaction this is an
acidic proton we'll deprotonate it again
with a basic enzyme residue so our
enzyme uses this carefully positioned
base to deprotonate coenzyme a and this
will attack at this carbonyl now we know
that we're going to push electrons up
and form a tetrahedral intermediate in
biochemistry we actually save steps
often by not showing the tetrahedral
intermediate forming so we know whenever
we attack a carbonyl the electrons come
up they push back down and then they
kick off the leaving group you should
know that mechanism from organic
chemistry but in biochemistry that whole
process is represented with two
abbreviated arrows so we can show this
just like that but we have to remember
our chemical rules and that we cannot do
sn2 chemistry at this sp2 center so this
is just an abbreviation some people like
to put another arrow to represent that
the electrons are coming up it forms an
intermediate and comes back down
but since biochemical mechanisms are so
long just using these
two blue arrows is completely acceptable
so we've gotten to our final product
acetyl coenzyme a and I'm realizing with
the second arrow I probably should have
grabbed a proton from the enzyme but I'm
not going to show that step I'll just
show the reduced form of Lippo ammon now
I mentioned that all coenzymes need to
go back to their original state for the
enzyme to be able to complete another
catalytic cycle but we've added
electrons to Lippo amat so we have it in
its reduced state if ad can come in
returning it to its cyclic oxidized form
to sum up TPP is a coenzyme that reacts
with carbonyl compounds it can be
deprotonated to form this illud which is
nucleophilic and once it does this
initial attack step on on some carbonyl
compound it's an electron sink and we
can push electrons through the system
neutralizing this positive charge to do
things like decarboxylation x' and TPP
is also involved in some other processes
that involve group transfer KP here if
you learn something give me a thumbs up
on the way out and for more chemistry
subscribe to my channel